[Musique]
bienvenue dans afrique honnête le 25
novembre l'afrique du sud a signalé à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
détection d'un nouveau variant omicron
le nombre d'infections est sans
précédent dans le pays qui fait face à
une quatrième vague l'afrique du sud et
toute sa région est isolée du monde
pourtant résilient au début de la
pandémie le continent se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans l'oeil du cyclone
omicron on se connecte tout de suite
avec l'expert santé à l' oms le docteur
thierno baldé bonjour docteur baldé vous
êtes à brazzaville merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans un frais connect
merci merci de m'avoir invité alors que
sait-on de ce variant omicron sa
dangerosité par rapport notamment aux
variants delta
lorsque les autorités puis la communauté
scientifique de l'afrique du sud on lui
a mentionné à l'organisation mondiale de
la santé donc la détection de ce nouveau
variant il avait des caractéristiques
bien particulières c'était le nombre
important de mutation ont été détectés à
travers ses valeurs la docu d'une
trentaine d'hommes de mutation ont été
découvertes au niveau de ce variant
retour d'un échantillon qui avait été
collecté environ il ya deux semaines il
ya deux semaines donc à ces sites c'est
cette caractéristique importante lors de
ce variant la qui a amené un peu toute
l'importance et toute l'attention autant
pour la communauté scientifique mais
surtout pour l'organisation mondiale de
la santé vous pouvoir donc à voir
quelles sont les implications
potentielles de ce nouveau variant
potentiellement quand même ayant
potentiellement des conséquences il par
rapport aux variants delta
le valais en delta est comme tous les
autres valiant avec des dégustations
deux ou trois mutations alors que celui
là on parle d'une trentaine de mutation
dont vous pouvez comprendre un peu la
différence et clairement là aussi
l'importante donc de pouvoir avoir une
connaissance beaucoup plus minutieuse de
ces éléments autour de ce souvenir là on
parle de 32 ans mutation dans sa
protéine spike c'est le varian donc le
plus contagieuses jusqu'à présent
il a montré ses caractéristiques de
contagiosité de transmissibilité c'est
quelque chose que nous sommes en train
d'observer depuis les trois dernières
semaines et dans le cas particulier de
l'afrique du sud on a vu une
augmentation hyperimportant tous état de
la transmission de ce ce valiant la
parra pour valiant d'état a donc le pic
de transmission de contagion est quand
même extrêmement élevé
alors justement docteur à thierno baldé
on va faire le point sur la situation et
l'évolution du variant omicron sur le
continent africain avec léa descazaux il
ne s'est écoulé que trois semaines
depuis la découverte du nouveau variant
au micro en crawl trois semaines pendant
lesquelles l'afrique du sud a connu une
augmentation exponentielle du nombre
d'infections au co vite 19 portant le
nombre total de contaminer à 3 millions
la multiplication de cas positifs est
largement due aux nouveaux variants
omicron désormais considérée comme
dominant dans le pays
actuellement nos tests ont augmenté de
façon spectaculaire passant de 4000 à
18000 test par jour ce qui nous montre
que les gens sont infectés et qu'ils ont
besoin de se faire tester
c'était l'équipe du professeur f6 yavar
d'as à johannesbourg que l'on doit la
découverte de ce nouveau variant
clairement observé que le variant delta
est écarté par aux microbes en l'espace
de deux semaines c'est vraiment rapide
mais on n'est pas sûrs de la raison
est-ce qu mikron est un virus plus
puissant et se transmet mieux ou est ce
que les gens ont baissé la garde se
réunissent et propagent le virus comme
ça ce qui peut aussi arriver
si au micro n'a été identifié ici en
afrique du sud rien ne prouve que c'est
dans cette zone géographique qu'il s'est
développé pourtant plusieurs pays
occidentaux ont pris la décision de
fermer leurs frontières aux
ressortissants d'afrique australe puni
pour son travail scientifique
l'afrique du sud est selon son président
cyril ramaphosa victime d'un apartheid
sanitaires
l'afrique du sud est fermement opposé à
toute forme d'apartheid sanitaire dans
la lutte contre la pandémie
want to use the opportunity to
excellence et je veux profiter de cette
occasion votre excellence pour appeler
une fois de plus les pays qui ont imposé
ces restrictions de voyage à revenir de
toute urgence sur leur décision a levé
ces interdictions et à permettre aux
gens de voyager l'appli pour
la découverte de ce nouveau variant
remet la question de l'inégalité
vaccinale sur la table même à l'échelle
du continent la fracture est visible les
pays prospère comme le maroc la tunisie
ou l'afrique du sud dispose d'une
couverture vaccinale plus élevé que leur
voisin tchadien soudanais ou congolais
alors que le royaume-uni la france ou
les états unis proposent déjà une
troisième dose de rappel l'om est-ce
souligne que seulement 5% de la
population d'afrique est entièrement
vacciner
alors l'afrique australe n'est pas la
seule région touchée on peut citer au
moment où l'on se parle dr thierno baldé
également l'afrique de l'ouest comment
la situation pourrait évoluer
alors on a vu qu'on vous l'avez si bien
dit l'afrique du sud est à sa quatrième
bague
continent africain ici on est
pratiquement la troisième vague on a
fini donc la troisième banque on a vu
une évolution
on a vu de la dynamique évolutive de
cette pandémie l'a souvent touché
énormément l'afrique australe continue
de beaucoup d'éléments appelés monde
vers l'afrique de l'est l'afrique de
l'ouest est finalement vers l'afrique
centrale c'est ce que nous avons observé
autour de la dernière vague la troisième
vague donc oui il ya certains pays
d'afrique de l'ouest aujourd'hui comme
le sénégal le nigeria ou encore le ghana
ou le bayern munich ont été détectées ne
savait il faut une conjonction de
beaucoup de facteurs pour expliquer un
peu la dangerosité à de ce type donc de
virus l'a donc les populations
évidemment entre les différents pays
peuvent être différents de leurs
caractéristiques démographiques peuvent
être différents leur charge de morbidité
aussi peut être différente donc tous ces
éléments là doivent être tenus à prendre
pour pouvoir anticiper autant que
possible mais qu'à cela ne tienne
définitivement l'om ainsi s'il a
encouragé supporter les pays à pouvoir
d'augmenter la vigilance la détection de
ces nouveaux variants là à travers donc
les processus de surveillance et
génomique et pouvoir aussi s'apprêter à
répondre de façon optimale et aussi à
temps a donc à toute explosion de
nouveaux cas est actuellement c'est que
l'on va en afrique du sud il ya un appui
qui a été critiqué un coup il ya une
réponse qui est en cours et donc voilà
au moniteur la situation on essaie donc
d'avoir une approche agile une approche
assez flexible et contextualisés afin de
pouvoir mieux répondre à ces situations
dr thierno baldé la présidente de
l'association médicale sud-africaine le
docteur angélique cozzi d'affirmer que
les premiers symptômes signalés étaient
légers sans exclure de potentiel signe
de gravité à venir on regarde cette
infographie
justement l' oms a averti face au danger
que représente au micro d' qui pour
l'instant à en croire le docteur cozzi
donc ne présente pas de forme grave chez
les personnes très jeunes est-ce que ça
d'abord c'est une tendance qui se
confirme et telles sont les informations
dont disposait ems
actuellement c'est que nous avons
constaté qui est aussi confirmé par les
autorités dans le sud africaine c'est
que le nombre d'hospitalisations n'a
également augmenté on n'est pas en train
de voir ici comme aux débuts de duvalier
en delta ici donc une augmentation
importante d'admission dans les sept
historiens animations donc ce n'est pas
ce qui est observé actuellement une fois
de plus ça me paraît un peu de temps
pour pouvoir voir l'effet que ça peut
avoir parce que l'éclosion initial aussi
a eu lieu dans des villes où il y avait
plus de jeunes hommes dans des milieux
scolaires donc définitivement des
personnes affectées on sait que les
jeunes sont moins affecté quelque part
donc par la sévérité de la maladie
voyons voir donne encore deux ou trois
semaines voir le comportement de virus
auprès d'autres types de population et
par l'ajout des conclusions qui sont
beaucoup plus robuste pourront être
tirés et se dit oui à quand à la
sévérité un peu de cette maladie là mais
à date je pense qu'il ya encore des
capacités qui existent ont mentionné que
il n'ya que 6 % des lits en réanimation
qui sont actuellement occupés par des
patients profitent à l'afrique du sud il
ya encore une grosse marche est un peu
qui existe au pouvoir adresser des
besoins vous quand ça se passerait ainsi
donc c'est la contagiosité qui inquiète
aujourd'hui l'om est ce parce que leur
mère ce je disais a averti face au
danger omicron oui la contagiosité elle
est importante mais qu'à cela ne tienne
on a encore tiré de conclusions sur la
sévérité de la maladie ni sur l'effet de
la maladie sur les vaccins ou encore sur
les traitements avec le scientifique
américain anthony fauci affirment qu'ils
pourraient être plus contagieux mais
moins sévère comme vous le disiez que le
variant delta veut dire
le premier enseignement que l'on
pourrait tirer finalement dû vario
mikron c'est qu' il ya des variants qui
vont être très contagieux mais moins
virulent c'est possible
une fois de plus je pense que ça nous
prendra un peu de temps pour pouvoir
attirer donc ses conclusions la hadda tu
sais c'est que nous sommes en train
d'observer mais encore il nous faut
encore une certaine marge donc demain
pour pouvoir attirer ces conclusions
avec un échantillonnage plus important
avec donc une représentativité
population est plus important sur les
étudiants qui sont en cours et peut-être
avec une étendue géographique aussi plus
importante une fois qu'on a tous ces
éléments l'on pourra faire des
inférences scientifiques qui nous
permettront de nous dire oui le
peut-être les prochains par y en a sont
plus contagieux au moins dangereux mais
peut-être juste si vous me permettez
mentionné que cette évolution les
banians qui apparaissent la somme des
évolutions naturelles de mutation de
virus donc c'est des choses qui arrivent
régulièrement et naturellement donc
évidemment plus à l'est le virus - ce
que le moins il ya de chances d'avoir
ces valeurs là donc ça ça me ramène
aussi à toute la problématique on parle
de nos micros maintenant mais le delta
est encore là les gens continuent à se
placer à transmettre la maladie donc il
nous faut continuer à appliquer ces
mesures là il nous faut continuer à
lutter contre la corrida son entièreté
pour pouvoir éviter que ce type dont
deux phénomènes la avait beaucoup plus
fréquemment mais le omicron qui a
dépassé les frontières du continent et
se trouve bien au delà est ce qu'il est
en passe finalement il ya une crainte de
voir au micro dépasser delta dans les
mois à venir
la dynamique la cinétique et un taux de
ce virus là reste à voir c'est sûr qu'on
a vu qu'en delta est arrivé delta qui a
pris toute la place au niveau donc de
haut niveau donc des différentes
variantes qui existaient notamment au
niveau du bétail de l'alpha est ce que
c'est le même phénomène mais comme on le
dit est ce que si aussi au micro et
moins et moins dangereux qu'au niveau
donc qu d'état peut-être que c'est pas
nécessairement le même phénomène que
nous allons observer donc je pense que
jusqu'à maintenant là on est encore dans
des hypothèses on est dans des
suppositions ont fait ce monitoring là
en fait cette observation afin de
pouvoir produit donc des bases solides
pour pouvoir donc alimenter les actions
en cours alors comment expliquer
l'apparition de micro non en afrique du
sud est ce que c'est l'inégalité
vaccinale entre les pays du nord est et
du sud qui peuvent être une explication
ça pourrait être un facteur mais ce
n'est pas essentiellement de ce facteur
parce que vous le savez à le var hier
d'état il a été aussi découverts en est
c'est vrai que le taux de vaccination à
l'époque était très bas le half a été
découvert en ue qui est là aussi
évidemment c'était au début de la
pandémie à vaccination n'était pas la
même gamme a aussi il était aussi au
niveau du brésil donc oui les valiant
ils peuvent apparaître un peu partout et
moi aujourd'hui on se dit aussi est ce
que vraiment c'est là où que ces valeurs
là il a apparu peut-être qu'il a été
rapporté la première fois sa scène
élément important mentionné parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit qu'il est
détectée dans d'autres pays ça qu'il y
ait nécessairement une histoire longue
de voyage un historique de voyage à
partir de l'afrique du sud donc m est
une bonne leçon activé c'est d'avoir les
capacités vraiment de détection à de
souvenirs là pour toute la communauté
mondiale on va dire parce que la
détection qui a été fait là et le
partage de cette information à temps
pour pouvoir permettre à tous les pays
de se préparer d'attirer leur attention
c'est quelque chose déjà d'importants
dommages et quelles sont les
informations dont vous disposez sur
l'efficacité finalement des vaccins à
protéger contre omicron on parle
actuellement d'une baisse
l'efficacité des vaccins contre ce
variant et selon l'étude il faudrait au
moins trois doses pour les vaccins à arn
on est au courant de ces informations là
quand on fait le parallèle avec le débat
c'est sûr que l'efficacité de certains
versets la bbc mais par contre les
vaccins permettait toujours quelque part
ici d'éviter la survenue des cas sévères
et des cas critiques donc à des malades
et c'est ça l'objectif véritablement de
ses parcelles il n'empêche pas ce que
quelqu'un tombe malade mais au moins ils
se cherchent à protéger parce que
déclare une certaine immunité donc à
l'égard donc du virus par contre ici
comme devant le disais il est encore
très tôt on est juste à deux semaines ou
trois semaines donc de la découverte de
ce nouveau variant là ça prendra un peu
plus de temps pour pouvoir analyser et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
travail différents partenaires
actuellement on travaille avec tous les
scientifiques pour pouvoir dont ils
essaient conclusion là le plus
rapidement que possible dr thierno baldé
on va marquer une courte pause et
poursuivre dans un instant restez avec
nous retour dans l'afrique honnête après
cette courte pause
[Musique]
recours adam afrique connect nous sommes
avec le docteur thierno baldé qui est
expert en santé à l'om est si on évoque
avec lui l'impact l'apparition de mikron
notamment en afrique sur le continent
africain dr thierno baldé le président
sud africain on va évoquer la
vaccination mais le président sud
africain il a quand même dénoncé un
apartheid sanitaire après l' isolement
des pays d'afrique australe l'om est ce
justement appelé à ne pas isoler cette
région quelles seraient les conséquences
d'un isolement prolongé
il ya des conséquences d'avoir de nature
quelque part sanitaire et de santé
publique parce qu'on sait que cette
isolation la langue
anglais à ne permet pas définitivement
de limites et donc la transmission de
cette maladie là ça c'est un fait
indéniable donc ça s'imprime est
l'élément mais notre élément aussi c'est
toutes les conséquences de nature
sociale et économique et puis la
stigmatisation un peu de ces pays là et
dès le départ donc l'om est quelque part
tenu à rappeler que elle se tenait
derrière un peu ces pays là pour pouvoir
conclure eu le courage l'audace it et de
partage est véritablement ces
informations aux temps forts à temps
comme je le disais avec le reste de la
communauté mondiale quelque part pour
pouvoir les protéger dans une certaine
mesure d'une centaine d'éléments
importants et à toutes les conséquences
aussi sociales économiques aujourd'hui
comme on le sait c'est l'été austral qui
va commencer du côté de l'afrique de
l'afrique du sud et des pays avoisinants
dont il ya tout là toute la composante
holistique de la composante économique
donc de ces pays là qui peut être
affecté par ces fermetures de frontières
et a évidemment on encourage les pays
qui ont imposé un peu c'est faire utile
a véritablement adopter d'autres mesures
qui sont des mesures qui sont plus
proportionnés qui sont beaucoup plus
rationnelle et puiqu'il s'appuie aussi
sur des évidences scientifiques pour
protéger leur population quelle mesure a
préconisé oms
par exemple le testing le testing que
l'on peut faire véritablement la de
testing à deux jours accroché à pour
certaines personnes qui venant de ces
pays là des investigations de cas qui
peuvent se faire aussi d'en savoir si
les personnes sont elles sont plus ou
moins à risque ou encore la quarantaine
c'est tout ça c'est des éléments je
pense qu'ils peuvent permettre à
d'éviter la stigmatisation ainsi que
l'on apprenne à vivre avec cette maladie
là et limiter les conséquences
économiques sociales de cette pandémie
la
102 millions d'africains vacciner 7 25%
de la population du continent il ya plus
de 80% de la population qui n'est pas
vaccinée dans les pays du nord avec
notamment l'apparition l'effet omicron
on est déjà passé à la troisième dose il
ya plusieurs mois l'om est ce justement
dénoncé les dose de rappel au regard de
cette inégalité vaccinale dans le monde
qu'elle est maintenant votre position l'
oms les commander dans une vaccination
avec deux doses additionnelles pour
certaines personnes en camping qui sont
à risque une certaine catégorie de
population mais avec ce nouveau variant
la cie les évidences scientifiques
mentionne ces éléments là à ce moment il
va falloir qu'on s'adapte et mais
clairement il n'y a pas que cette
composante là qui ferait même peut-on
tout cette composante de vaccination
il ya beaucoup d'autres éléments savez
pendant toute l'année il ya eu
énormément de défis pour pouvoir avoir
une quantité optimale dons de vaccins
dont l'organisation est un peu de cette
vaccination dans les offres qui sont
faites avec parfois des doses dont qui
ont détruit deux relativement à limiter
ou alors tout l'appui opérationnel
bien que cette vaccination de la banque
c'est une problématique quand même qui
est assez complexe qui a plusieurs
dimensions donc donc il faut essayer
donc de voir ensemble voire de soufisme
question est ce que les pays du nord les
pays les plus avancés en matière de
couverture vaccinale doivent freiner
justement le processus d dose de rappel
on se rend compte qu'on vit dans un
monde interconnecté donc à notre
directeur général a toujours l'habitude
de dire quelque part tant que en fait on
n'a pas su protéger personne n'est
protégé donc il faut qu'on gars là à
l'évidence les villes du sud ne
connaissent pas de frontières il nous
faut avoir ici une logique toujours
quelque part être globale pour pouvoir
avoir une bonne partage avec une
certaine équité dont des vaccins
existants pouvoir capacité tous les
différentes et limiter la transmission
dans tous les pays sinon à les
conséquences elles sont lancées
l'arrivée un peu de ce type d'homme de
valiant et qui n'a pas de frontières qui
n'ont pas de frontières qui peut passer
d'un pays à l'autre d'un continent à un
autre est ce que vous estimez que si on
ne comble pas finalement cette fracture
vaccinale est la course mondiale contre
l'apparition des nouveaux variants et
est perdu d avance
il faut il faut faire un effort
supplémentaire il faut faire vraiment de
gros efforts à pour pouvoir donc avancer
effectivement dans la couverture
vaccinale pour limiter un peu toutes ses
conséquences la donc d'abord pour sauver
des vies parce que les vaccins sauvent
des vies mais également pour prévenir
l'apparition un peu de tout c'est
variable dont on est en train de parler
maintenant ils pouvoir donc pouvoir
mieux se préparer à la porte donc à
d'autres éventuels à d'éventuelles
crises de cette nature là est ce que
vous croyez vous que l'arrivée des
nouveaux variants comme nikon
potentiellement donc très contagieux va
pousser les états à un moment donné a
levé les brevets pour réduire cette
inégalité vaccinale et permettra au pays
d'élaborer
leur propre vaccin je pense qu'on est
déjà en tête dans cette logique là est
définitivement ce type d'événement là
vient rappeler à quoi la pertinence
l'importance et l'urgence donc de
pouvoir les wc preuve est là et pouvoir
donc démocratiser davantage donc c'est
bien là c'est bien de ses biens de santé
publique la comme la vaccination et
permettent donc à ces noms mais beaucoup
plus important don de deux personnes
donc et accès à ces vaccins pour sauver
des vies et pour pouvoir continuer à
vivre aussi mais quand vous dites qu'on
est déjà dans qu'on va vers dans ce sens
ce n'est pas certain parce qu'on attend
encore un geste de la part justement des
pays du nord on sait que l'om est
soutient l'initiative de pretoria et de
new delhi auprès de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce dans ce sens
d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui va arriver
dans les prochains mois est ce que à ce
niveau la levée des brevets vous pensez
vraiment que il y aura des résultats
concrets
mais nous l'espérons mais quand je le
disais tout à l'heure aux 6es toutes les
initiatives de production locale un peu
qu'ils sont en cours avec différents
mécanismes évidemment l'arrivée de
brevets sénateurs le transfert des
connaissances et des compétences en
mener d'autres les pouvoir investir
davantage dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette industrie manufacturière la de
vaccins dans certaines parties de la
région qui ont commencé en afrique du
sud du côté du maroc et puis encore du
côté du côté du sénégal donc tous ces
éléments là je pense qu'on est dans
cette voie là mais il faut
définitivement aller plus vite il faut
une certaine autonomisation un peu de la
région africain a pour pouvoir donc
prendre en charge ou au mieux à la
population dont la population africaine
mais aussi la population en général dans
le monde mais vous croyez que justement
l'arrivée de nouveaux vaccins sur le
marché continental va résoudre le
problème parce qu'on sait que la
faiblesse de la couverture vaccinale sur
le continent africain elle est aussi
liée au scepticisme des populations qui
refuse de servir en quelque sorte de
cobaye à des vaccins qui ne sont pas
homologués en europe par exemple
les vaccins la plupart des personnes qui
sont disponibles qui avait d'autre part
à ma fille qui s'y sont des passants qui
se sont passés à travers les terres de
validation de la communauté scientifique
sous la coordination de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé tous les vaccins
qui passe par les mécanos du proverbe
kovacs ou encore des mécanismes à rabat
sont ces vaccins l'a donc véritablement
je pense que ces deux vaccins qui
répondent absolument mêmes critères un
peu de validité de scientificité avec
tous les autres vaccins qui sont juste
oublié dans les autres régions du monde
mais un point important que vous avez
mentionné évidemment il s'agit de
convaincre davantage les gens à aller se
faire vacciner donc ça c'est un élément
important et je pense qu'il ya une
grande bataille à mener ici dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois pour convaincre donc les
populations africaines qui sont resté
longtemps aussi sans avoir ces parcelles
là pour qu'ils aient accès à ces
parcelles l'a donc pour qu'ils acceptent
français par ça alors il ya un
scepticisme des populations mais le
manque de doses aussi vous faisiez
allusion au système kovacs le bilan de
kovacs il faut en parler quand même
parce que fin novembre
737 millions de doses envoyées sur les 1
20 46 milliards prévus on est quand même
loin du compte est-ce que là l'om est-ce
tape du poing sur la table et dénonce un
échec
il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu des enjeux il
ya eu des enjeux majeurs vous savez un
moment donné il ya eu toute cette crise
là avec le delta donc dans cette
industrie là donc en m qui était censé
fournir un peu les parcelles pour le
mécanisme kovacs il ya eu beaucoup
d'éléments dont qui se sont passées
depuis le mois de juillet jusqu'au 20
novembre mais ce qui est important aussi
a mentionné c'est qu'il ya maintenant
quand même une à une exportation assez
importante elle n'en voit assez
importante de vaccins dans la région
dont il ya une il ya quand même des
recettes et une certaine évolution de la
disponibilité des vaccins
l'enjeu aujourd'hui une fois de plus
auparavant c'était cela la disponibilité
de ces vaccins sur terre c'est arrivé
aussi coordonner parce que une chose
c'est de les amener une autre chose
c'est de les prévenir et d'organiser ne
pas juste les recevoir comme ça avec des
durées de vie qui sont à ses côtés comme
ça ils ne peuvent pas être véritablement
être utilisées aujourd'hui à des pays
qui ont fait la démonstration d'une
capacité optimale à pouvoir du soulier
des vaccins des pays comme le rwanda par
exemple qui déçoit des vaccins qui les
fascine qui sont passés maintenant même
à la vaccination des adolescents il ya
le moins en plus quand même qu'ils sont
là il faudrait qu'on encourage qu'on
accompagne les autres pays qui n'ont pas
encore ceux des blés un peu d'agilité
dans cette vitesse d'administration des
personnes à pouvoir le faire aussi or la
chine a promis un milliard de doses il
s'agira de dons de soutien justement à
la production locale où on en est au
niveau de la recherche d'un vaccin sur
le continent
je pense que cette annonce n'a été faite
la semaine dernière donc c'est quelque
chose que nous savons évidemment à
l'arrivée de davantage de vaccins sur la
région dans le continent c'est quelque
chose de très positif donc ça c'est une
initiative véritablement à saluer et
puis à toutes les autres actions qui
veut devrait encourager aussi
véritablement la production la
génération de nouvelles innovations qui
pourraient nous permettre donc d'avoir
cette couverture vaccinale mais aussi
tous les autres - ne dépose pas ce que
les vaccins constituent un élément mais
il ya tous les autres éléments
aujourd'hui par exemple la prise en
charge d'une oxygénothérapie quand les
gens sont malades il faut les médecins
exigent les cas critiques et les cas
sévères
comment est-ce qu'on augmente un peu la
production la distribution de ces
éléments là comment est-ce qu'on protège
les parieurs de santé avec les matériels
de protection individualiser les gares
les blues tous ces éléments là sont très
importants les antibiotiques les
corticoïdes tous ces éléments là sont
importants car est à prendre en
considération pour que l'on ait l'effet
escompté donc sur
2001 l'om est d'ailleurs qui dénonce
le manque de vaccination chez les
personnels soignants sur ce niveau quels
sont les observations des ems et comment
l'expliquer
il faut se dire que le personnel
soignant si c'est une catégorie de la
société
donc lorsqu'on a fait affaire à des
enjeux de manque de vaccins moins de
difficultés pour atteindre ces personnes
là c'est toujours difficile donc c'est
csi du personnel qui est à risque c'est
du personnel qui est à risque non
seulement pour la copie de 19 mais aussi
c'est le personnel qui a en charge en
fait de traiter d'autres patients donc
imaginez vous quand on a pas de médecins
et d'infirmiers est assez de l'hôpital
pour traiter des enfants qui sont
atteints lors de la malaria ou encore d
autres maladies diarrhéiques à des pneus
nice est une autre problématique qui est
là donc c'est pour cette raison-là ces
différentes approches la holistique pour
pouvoir d'en donner tout le support
nécessaire à son personnel soit natal la
vaccination les matériels de protection
individualisé de recruter un peu plus de
personnes pour pouvoir faire face aux
besoins croissants donc par rapport aux
maladies donc c'est ce qui nous
permettait un peu d'arriver à une
utilisation optimale des ressources et
peut-être limité à l'impact de cette
pandémie là dans la région vous savez
que le débat il est où le partout dans
le monde sur la vaccination obligatoire
en tout cas l'afrique du sud y réfléchit
est ce que les pays africains ont
intérêt à ouvrir ce débat là aussi un
bon
organisation technique on l a
définitivement vous conseillez les états
membres on a vu que certains pays ont eu
la mettre en place donc des mesures
d'encouragement quelques pas pour que
les gens donc accepte de se faire
vacciner donc c'est des éléments il faut
expliquer il faut une approche
pédagogique parfois il faut plusieurs
moyens pour amener les gens à changer de
comportement
on ne change pas le comportement
l'attitude la réception d'un adulte
après très facilement vous et moi on ne
peut pas me convient très très
facilement de changer sur la fois en
france donc il me faut donc du temps
nous faut prendre toutes les mesures et
certaines mesures législatives
nationales donc ça ne pouvait être mise
en place pour encourager les gens
vraiment à se faire vacciner il à se
protéger contre cette maladie la poule
bien-être collectif une fois de plus
mais c'est un débat qu'il faut ouvrir
sur le continent là le débat autour de
la vaccination obligatoire
je pense qu'il existe des gens et donc
il nous faut quand même avoir les titres
toutes les bonnes parties prenantes et
avoir donc des décisions les plus
éclairés qu'on fasse les évaluations les
plus importantes et avec les voix de
tout le monde je pense que c'est des
choix de société qu'il faut faire il
faut faire des choix entre par exemple
de bien-être individuel versus de
bien-être collectif qu'est ce que l'on
choisit quelque part
merci beaucoup à vous dr thierno baldé
c'est moi qui vous remercie pour
l'opportunité
et merci aux équipes du mag et
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis retrouver après connecte sur nos
réseaux sociaux et notre site internet
arte france pointe river à très bientôt
dans un trait connecte sur rt france